antonio brown officially part of the
buccaneers roster today
activated to the 53-man roster now that
his suspension has ended remember he's
not out of the woods he could face
further action from the league or the
buccaneers could cut him
based upon how this pending civil
lawsuit for sexual assault is resolved
he'd like to get
a continuance of a trial that is set for
december of this year
that was some documentation that broke
overnight here's tom brady talking to
jim gray of westwood one on last night's
monday night football pregame show
regarding the reality that antonio brown
has been living at brady's house
antonio's a good friend of mine and
again we've gotten to know each other
pretty well over the years so
he's just getting settled and i know
he's looking for places
but it's just nice to be able to to have
him around and
you know we're getting to work and he
likes to be integrated into what we're
doing and
big transition for him moving across the
state and really not know anyone so
you know again just trying to be a great
teammate and help someone out
you know as a is a friend of mine
yeah i don't think tom brady is such a
great teammate that any new arrivals in
tampa bay
can move into the house he's renting
from derek jeter this is more than just
being a great teammate
there's a relationship there however it
happened
in a short time in new england brady and
brown became
very very good friends and i personally
think that this antonio brown
tampa bay thing was in the works for
months i wouldn't be surprised if bruce
arians deliberately downplayed it so
people wouldn't see it coming
i think antonio brown's had the playbook
for a long time
and i would guess that he's been staying
at tom brady's house from time to time
for a while now and working out with tom
brady and getting to know the offense
they've been they've been too
strangely tight-lipped about things
before his arrival
things that happened before his arrival
to make me think otherwise
now he's officially part of the team and
in five nights we get to see what he's
going to do
in three and four receiver sets mike
evans said last night he looks forward
to antonio brown
drawing double coverages away from him
which is kind of conceiting antonio
brown's better than mike evans if he's
going to draw a double coverage away
from mike evans you get both those guys
on the field though the saints are going
to have a hell of a
decision to make if brown is able to hit
the ground uh running the way that the
buccaneers seem to think he will shireen
mike i hope giselle has made it clear to
antonio brown that he can't start
throwing furniture around
the house you know he's done that
unfortunately they're not done
yeah fortunately it's a low-level house
so he could he could throw some
furniture into the water
right make sure no boats are out there
when he does it but at least it's not 14
stories down to the ground level if
antonio brown gets upset but yeah i'm
sure that i'm sure that
gisele laying down the law about one
antonio brown cannon can't throw out the
window
and you know what it reminds me of mike
is when t.o accused jason witten and
tony roma of drawing up plays in their
hotel room
on road games because they did room
together on the road but
you know they're drawing up plays you
know they're talking about the game at
night when they get home what they're
going to do and
for whatever reason tom brady has just
not found that connection with mike
evans
and we know mike evans is one of the
best receivers in football and he had
the touchdown last night but that
connection
just is not there so maybe when a b
gets there that connection improves and
the chemistry improves between mike
evans
and tom brady but it's not been there so
far and that's unfortunate
and then when they get chris godwin back
i mean heck who do you
who do you double there that's just a
nightmare for defensive coordinators and
i think this offense is just gonna we
didn't see it click last night but i
think
by the end of the season if all those
guys stay healthy this is going to be an
offense you definitely don't want to
play in the playoffs
but you know look at that graphic that
we just had if we can put it back up
evans gets targeted a lot more and is a
lot more productive
without chris godwin on the field which
makes you wonder whether or not there is
that connection
between evans and brady and here's the
thing
it's um first of all mike evans isn't
wired
to be like t.o and complain that he
thinks that
the quarterback and another receiver are
conspiring against him and trying to
keep the ball
from him evans is mature evans is
positive
evans isn't selfish he welcomes antonio
brown being there he was interviewed
last night by lisa solders
after the win over the giants and he
seems genuine he doesn't seem capable of
guile he's a very
what you see is what you get and i've
always liked mike evans he's
he doesn't have a lot to say if you
interview him you better be ready with
another question because you never know
if you're just going to get a one-word
answer
but i i don't have any problem with him
causing a ruckus because he thinks
suspects or concludes
that brady and brown are working
together to come up with ways to get
antonio brown the football
yeah he would never do that mike and i
go way back with mike evans to his days
at texas a
m when he was with johnny and winning
johnny a heisman frankly
but he's a he's a great guy like you
said he's never not going to complain
about not getting the ball
he's a consummate teammate he's a good
team leader
he's very much better in 101s than he is
in a group
interview i know that for sure but yeah
he's not going to complain and i think
that's why bruce arians and tom brady
love him so much
is because he doesn't complain about not
getting the ball he's not your diva
receiver for sure but ab four catches
for 56 yards and a touchdown the last
time he played that was with tom brady
in week two last year it's been a long
time since we've seen him
i cannot wait for sunday night i just
think this is going to be fun
well and the last time we saw him play
the saints was his last game
with the steelers december 2018
targeted 19 times 14 catches
185 receiving yards and two touchdowns
and that was the game
that saw juju smith schuster fumble away
the ball
the steelers lost to the saints 31-28
smith shuster was the goat they got
knocked out of the playoffs two days
later
the steelers announced which no team
should do during the season
the steelers announced that the mvp for
the team for 2018 was juju's miss
shuster
antonio brown got his nose out to join
antonio brown through the ball at ben
roethlisberger reportedly stormed out
never returned and that was that for
antonio brown and pittsburgh after that
great game against the saints
and the saints are gonna have their
hands full i'm sure we'll be talking a
lot about this game as the week unfolds
they're gonna have their hands full
figured out what to do with brown
and with mike evans and gronk and chris
godwin if he can play and scottie miller
and good luck trying to slow down that
offense so i think brown is going to
have a big game
i think part of justifying the move
to get brown the faith in brown all the
talk about brown
is to use him so everyone will say well
now we know why
you did what you did because he can come
out and produce
like he did the last time we saw him
with the steelers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports